charles right well good evening
everybody welcome to the
last cabinet meeting of 2020 both those
that are participating and those who are
watching
home on the live stream uh if members
have technical difficulties during the
meeting please contact the democratic
services officer on call who will
attempt to assist you
on call today is katie brewer and her
number is 577046
it will also be at the top of the chat
thread for members if you need it
for those of you who are watching by the
council's youtube stream please follow
the instructions below the video if
there are any issues with the live feed
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please mute your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side of the screen
and i'll make a note and get back to you
once the person speaking is finished
please note we will be following the
usual cabinet protocols in which other
members of the council
usually only speak once on each item
with everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they're not used to make or receive
phone calls while the meeting's in
progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
please note that the meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
will also be recorded and subsequently
made available on the internet
can i ask members of the cabinet to
confirm that they're present in the
meeting
when they read out when i read out their
name i'll ask for the attendance of
those counsellors while participating in
order to speak under council procedure
rule 20.1 separately
councillor alvin yeah here chair thank
you
uh councillor yates here
uh i don't know whether councillor
whitehead has joined us yet she was
hoping to join but she's on childcare
duty
so we'll see whether she makes it or not
but she sends her apologies if she
doesn't make it
and councillor duckworth has sent her
apologies
so the following members have asked to
speak under the procedure
20.1 so when i say your name can you
please confirm your present in the
meeting
on item four i've got councillor garner
i'm here chair thank you councillor
david saunders
i'm here chair thank you and councillor
bailey
yeah chad thank you and then item five
i've got councillor connor again
councillor pugh uh here chair
thank you and councillor ashby and i see
we've been joined by councillor
whitehead
here chair that council ashby i'm sorry
cancer
well i canceled wyber yeah she's never
joined us
so we're moving to the agenda as i said
we've got apologies for cancer duckworth
everybody else is here does anybody have
any declarations of interest in respect
of items
of business on the agenda this evening
i'm not seeing any thank you minutes of
the previous meeting uh cabinet is asked
to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
meeting held on the 19th of november
uh i will propose the minutes can i have
a second to please
yeah i'll second that chair that's
seconded by councillor album thank you
unless i hear any objection i'll take
these minutes as approved
those are approved so we move on to item
four which is the park avenue brawl
stairs petition
which is for me to introduce
so this petition was reported to the
full council meeting on the 10th of
september
and accordance in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
it was referred to cabinet the report
outlines an
update on the two matters raised by the
petition about the site on park avenue
broadstairs
these were for the council to require
the owner of the site to
replant any trees covered by tree
protection orders within that area
following the recent heavy felling and
to reaffirm its current view that the
area should remain as open space stroke
woodland
the report provides the cabinet with
information on the planning department's
investigation
into the alleged breach of tree
preservation orders on the site
which has occurred independently through
delegated processes
it's quite important uh particularly for
members of the public to understand that
these
these matters are not dealt with by a
cabinet um they're actually dealt with
through
separate processes the responsibilities
of cabinet are set out and delegated
um through the council constitution and
through law and they don't include
um tackling planning enforcement matters
and three tree preservation order
breaches
nevertheless the petition comes having
it and that's why we're able to discuss
it this evening
this has resulted in a tree replacement
notice being served on 12 trees
considered to be protected by
the orders on site and this notice was
served on the owner of the land
requiring those trees to be planted
by the 31st of march 2021
the report also outlines the process for
of consideration of whether the site in
question
should be designated as open space would
land
cabinet is asked to agree to include
consideration of open space and green
infrastructure in the district within
the local plan review
in accordance with the separate cabinet
report on the agenda
this evening uh and i'll call in
councillor garner
thank you chair um well firstly i'd like
to thank all
in planning and legal who've worked to
complete this report into the felling of
over 40 trees
at park avenue and for issuing the
treaty planting notice on the landowner
it's good to see the council start to
take the illegal felling of trees in
planet seriously
as i've said previously there's a
growing strength of feeling across the
district
as shown by recent demonstrations at
park avenue
cliftonville bowls club and in margaret
old town and other parts of planet
the wider community of thanet feels
that action needs to be taken i hope the
tree replacement order
is a first step as i believe we should
be looking to take legal action against
landowners
who illegally fell trees covered by tpos
especially those who have tree
replanting notices served on them
which clearly indicate that the trees
were indeed covered
and permission should have been sought
to do any work on them
if we as a council do not start taking
legal action
we are signaling to others that they can
do the same with impunity
thank you thank you uh
councillor ghana um i i would just say
that um
officers have considered what the most
appropriate action to take in this case
is
in order to remedy the breach in line
with the council's protocols
they've also taken external legal advice
and the action taken to require the
planting of the trees is considered to
be the most appropriate way to remedy
the breach
which is what the council needs to do
and protect the immunity of the area i i
do understand
the desire to see some other action
um but what the planning department is
charged to do here is to
remedy the breach and that is my
understanding of what they've tried to
do
counselor david saunders
thank you leader as world council i
would also like to recall
my thanks to the officers for their
diligence in assembling
irrefutable evidence regarding 12
disappointingly only 12 of the 41 plus
mature and semi-mature
trees failed over that weekend of the
29th and 30th of february
on behalf of the landowners park stairs
limited
i know from my own inquiries that this
was not a straightforward investigation
given the difficulty of clearly
identifying those individual trees still
covered by
tpos particularly following various
residential developments
within park avenue and particularly
around this location
since that tree register was last uh
reviewed
so therefore having said that and and
reinforcing exactly what the leaders now
said is now to be hoped that park stairs
limited will comply with the tree
replacement order
by the 31st of march 2021
without the need for further
intervention thank you
thank you councillor saunders i don't
think i need to add to that and
obviously i
i echo the comments of members on
thanking the officers for their work on
this because i know that uh
with documents going back to 1956 a long
while before vanity district council
existed
it's been quite a challenge for them um
councillor bailey
good evening um yeah a lot of what i was
going to be
sorry a lot of what i was going to say
has been said but i i will reiterate it
because um
i think as a well i'll start off as one
of the ward councillors i just want to
thank everyone involved for persevering
with this and taking it seriously
because i know obviously it's been a
very hard year and been a lot of
pressures on everyone's time
um it was very welcome news to hear that
the order being made to replant the 12
tpo trees
and that recommendation has been put
forward to consider
this area and other green areas as just
as designated
open spaces in the local green um sorry
the local plan review
however the park avenue group do feel
strongly that the council should go one
step further and prosecute the landowner
especially if this replanting isn't
complied with
they fully understand that there needs
to be a high threshold of evidence
before any legal action is taken
we have discussed this um
and that any costs would come from the
public purse but now the council has
spent nine months on collating all this
evidence
as outlanding point 2.2 of the report
and in the long run we feel a successful
prosecution will send out strong message
to others
who may be thinking doing the same thing
uh maybe saving the council time and
money
in similar situations going forward in
the future
so yeah maybe a stitch in time type
principle
um anyway many thanks to the officers
and staff involved in the investigation
and enforcement of the um
of this matter so far been very
appreciated thank you
thank you councillor bailey and just one
thing i'll i'll add on the subject of
prosecution because i did have a
discussion with this
uh with mr living about this with mr
livingston uh planning applications
manager
uh and um he makes the point that a
prosecution would not actually be a
material consideration if a future
planning application came forward
on the site whereas the council's action
in requiring the uh
replanting of the trees or the planting
of new trees to replace the trees
covered by the tpo would be a material
consideration
so i think that's important because i
know that residents are concerned to
protect the future of the site
um but we understand that residents
would like to see different things
happening but obviously the officers
have looked at this very carefully and
they have taken legal advice
and that's how they've decided to
proceed so
members the only um thing that we have
to do here i think
is to note the ongoing enforcement
action
uh and to agree to include the
consideration of open space agreed
infrastructure
within local plan review which is the
next item so
unless i hear any do you wish to see
that
album do come here yes thanks leader and
i just wanted to come back uh to count
councillor ghana
and um and the way other members are
speaking relating
to this whilst i fully support what that
what they're saying
but i think it's very important uh for
the public
for our residents to know that
uh this council has always taken
uh action against uh preserved trees
when they've been cut down
or uh been uh
pollarded without any consent and the
same in the conservation areas
we've always done it personally as as a
former council officer i'd certainly
done it myself
and i've been to court on sev on several
occasions so i think it's very important
uh that this one incident large as
though it
it is um is is not seen as basically a
one-off thing that's happened and now
we're going to start
taking some action the council has
always taken action and i think that
that's
important um but also
uh i also think it's important as
as well for members to um to understand
that um
obviously the the person in relation
who's
instigated these removal of
the trees has the right of appeal
against this
uh tree replacement notice
and then if if he loses the appeal
um then and then doesn't plant
the trees in the specified time the
council can take direct action and plant
the trees itself
and then charged the um owner
of the land for the planting of those
trees
and and i again i think that that's
important and
i certainly support the leader's view
this is a very complicated case
i did deal with one myself previously of
which we took such a case to call and we
lost
because there wasn't sufficient evidence
and
and that cost the council a lot a lot of
costs
so for for me the way this has been
handled
has been spot on and totally support
thank you lina thank you councillor
alvin and as always
we benefit from your lengthy experience
of these matters
as a council officer so unless i hear
any objection i'm going to take the
recommendations as approved
thank you and we move on to item 5 which
is the local plan review
and update and local development scheme
which is me as well
so every local planning authority has to
prepare and maintain a work program for
its local plan related work known as the
local development scheme
this is a requirement under the planning
and compulsory purchase act
2004. in january 2019 the secretary of
state issued a direction to this council
in relation to the local plan
part of the direction was to amend the
council's local development scheme
to provide for the completion of a
review of the local plan within six
months of his adoption
this was also a recommendation by the
local plan inspectors
the local plan was adopted by the
council on the 9th of july 2020 which
means that the
review should be completed by january
2021
with a new lds published the review
to be clear is the process of assessing
whether a local plan
needs to be updated and if so what the
scope of that update would be
this is the assessment that has been
taking place over the last few months
and once that decision is made which is
the report being considered by cabinet
tonight
the substantive work of updating the
local plan can begin
this includes the whole process from
evidence gathering and engagement and
consultation
right through to the examination and
adoption of a new plan
during the last few months a cabinet
advisory group including members from
all political groups
has been considering the scope of the
local plan update and identifying local
issues that need to be addressed in the
update of the plan
the report before us also considers
other elements of local planning policy
and whether they need to be updated
and the key elements of the local
development scheme the local planned
work program
are set out in this report this work
will enable the council to deal with
some planning issues that could not be
addressed at the previous examination
for example manchester airport uh gypsy
and traveller sites
and reflect changes in government policy
in relation to climate change and the
council's own declaration of a climate
emergency
and to consider a range of important
local issues
and i just want to make clear because i
know there's been some confusion on this
point
um that the uh the work will include
considering the outcome
of the um process going on around
manchester nepal but at the moment there
is no
outcome as far as we understand it
but because of the time scale over which
this work will take place we expect
there to be an
outcome by the time we have to bring
forward um
the proposals for uh consultation
an examination so um we're not
proceeding on the basis of anything that
we've heard
we that will actually take place on the
basis of what happens what unfolds over
the coming months
so i moved the recommendation in the
report
is there a seconder i'm happy it's a
second
secondly by councillor yates
um and we will hear from
um councillor ghana please
well thank you leader um as you know
i've i've been part of the local plan
cabinet advisory group
and i think there are a number of good
recommendations
which i look forward to being included
in the updated local plan
i just wanted to highlight a couple of
these and also seek assurance that the
local plan is updated as soon as
possible
with all of the recommendations firstly
linking into the previous item on the
agenda
you'll know that at the september
council meeting
when discussing the tree filling at park
avenue we unanimously agreed to
designate the area where the trees were
filled
as an open space to help prevent the
possibility of any future development
there
bearing in mind what was said about the
tree planting
notices i think that alongside the
enforcement action already taken
it's important that this is considered
and implemented
as soon as possible the other
item i'd just like to highlight is a
number 17 on the list
which is to consider the evidence for
possible policy relating to hot food
takeaways
in relation to local public health
impacts
there are a number of studies that have
found a link between the over
concentration of
and proximity of fast food outlets and
devising obesity
especially among children and we also
know that the increase in obesity levels
raises the risk of other health issues
including type 2 diabetes heart disease
and now coronavirus
policy sp38 in the new plan seeks to
improve the health of planets residents
and reduce health inequalities and i
believe we need an amendment
to complement this which would in
practice
prevent any new hot food takeaways being
able to open
within 400 metres of a local school
we know a number of other local
authorities have been able to do this
and i think it's important for us to be
seen as taking this serious
issue this issue seriously i mean as
well as
actually taking it seriously thank you
yeah thank you councillor garner and i
think that um all those
matters are going to be addressed i
think we're going to have a
a further working group to provide input
during the actual
consideration of policy changes and
we'll be able to have an opportunity to
underline our commitment to the things
you said there i think as you
as you know we can't tonight um and as
part of
what we're doing here tonight make any
um specific allocation of
um to in respect of a particular site
all we can do is reaffirm our commitment
to
consider open spaces and green
infrastructure in the district within
the review
and i know that um some members of the
public would like us to
make a particular recommendation that's
not the role of cabinet it's not the
role of tonight's meeting
but it is something that members can
take forward um
during the process to follow and as
we're doing things as quickly as
possible there is a timetable set out in
the report
and obviously changes to the local plan
have to go through a formal process
um there has to be engagement there has
to be inspection and there has to be
adoption so
that's the process and that's the
timetable that we're bringing forward
tonight
uh councillor pugh
thank you leader um yeah two quick
questions from me i think you've already
addressed my question about madison
airport but i think i have a
supplement to that anyway um but firstly
as it mentions in the report
the local plan is now being used local
plan review is being used
to look for a temporary site for
travelers my question is considering the
amount of distress that the
uh previously previous proposals caused
residents um and the ongoing costs that
this council has to incur for
traveller incursions um and removing
waste and everything like that
um what are the time skills for this
particularly how long is it going to
take and as you said the local plan
review is going to be quite a long
process
um and i don't really think it's
particularly fair for residents to have
to endure any more distress
than necessary but also as well is it a
priority
within the local plan review uh with how
quickly it will
be resolved and we'll have a site that
is safe for travellers
um and also as well doesn't cause
distress to residents
um my second question you mentioned
about madison airport
and that you know of course the local
plan review as it is designed to do
um is there to adapt to changes and
we're all aware of the current uh
differences with the dco process for
madison airport
but also as well how one how much of a
priority is that
and two if the change in designation
does happen to madison airport as the
outcome of
due to the outcome of the dco and
everything else you know how will that
impact on the housing allocations across
the district
and i'm thinking mainly not only just my
own wards but of course burch and
westgate
where additional housing numbers and
allocations were added on
um as madison airport was taken out of
the suitable you know suggested sites
uh for the local plan a couple of years
ago
thank you councillor pew um in respect
of the um
the traveller sites i think one of the
one of the things that we wanted to do
and one of the reasons why we put this
back into the
review process in terms of the temporary
site allocation which is you know as a
subject
some controversy in areas that were
suggested for that is in order to have a
proper engagement a proper consultation
and a proper inspection so i do think it
is
you know it's vital that we do these
things in a
certainly in a timely way but we have a
timetable for adoption of the uh
the changes to the local plan as i said
earlier in the document
um and it will be managed within that
timetable
um obviously there will be consideration
of what appropriate sites are and that
will emerge and be discussed during the
process and again
members will have an opportunity to
import on that um but
i can't promise you that the the changes
are going to take place faster than the
adoption of the
of the new new version of the local plan
because clearly they're not
in terms of how they're adopted um i'll
let mr beryl perhaps comment on that and
if he wants to say anything about
housing numbers
i know it's very difficult to go
backwards in planning terms
um but perhaps he'll come in and explain
about that
yeah thank you chair um now that those
sites have been allocated through the
local plan and the plan has been found
sound and adopted it's actually quite
difficult to row back from that
um there is a good chance that we may
have to find additional housing sites
through the local plan review and update
so
there's not really any option to go back
and
and remove sites um just on egyptian
traveler sites
uh yes i mean we we will be looking at
the sites where
the intention is to have a call for
sites early in the new year
and then to carry out site assessments
and obviously
the local plan update group will
have direct input into that process um
yes i don't think that was the two
points that were raised
um but happy to answer any other
questions thank you mr phil
uh and i'm calling cancer ashby
thank you leader yeah um i'm wondering
uh if it's known what percentage of the
17
140 housing provision is planned to be
built or has been built
on agricultural land which is leading me
onto
the the the matter of the use of the
so-called mutant algorithm
which no doubtly which no doubt totally
overestimated
our district's requirement and failed to
realize our shortage of brownfield sites
is now being heavily criticized by the
southeast
mps how will we make provision
within the plan to facilitate the
possible shift of government policy to
leave farmland for growing
crops thank you well i'll let mr beryl
speak about the
the proportions obviously one of the
issues with with a plan is it is a plan
and we can't specifically control which
sites come forward first and i'll
develop first
um in terms of the mutant algorithm my
understanding is that it doesn't make a
great deal of difference in planet
um so whilst i i i hear what you're
saying about the
the large um clamor um among southeast
mps i think because of the
uh price of land or the value of land
infante in particular probably
um we weren't seeing a significant
change in their housing numbers
um based on that calculation but i let
mr verrill who's
far greater technical grasp for these
matters than me expand on that
thank you chair yeah the what's called
the standard method
and as your right has been referred to
as the mutant algorithm
they had an original standard method
which includes
a calculation based on population and
household growth
and affordability that was changed or
was proposed to be changed and i think
it was that
that there was a lot of objection to the
government
have announced just yesterday i think it
was
that they are going to revert to the
original standard method
but to provide some uplift in the larger
urban areas and cities so
um the idea would be that a greater
proportion would be in
the bigger cities in the country that
doesn't make
a an awful lot of difference in terms
of the numbers as far as we're concerned
uh the numbers in sanet in relation to
the proposed
second method went slightly down uh
and they've gone slightly back up to
where they were before so as the leader
says that
the the actual impact on the numbers in
sanet is quite small
um in relation to the portion of
brownfield
um we did a calculation
um back in 2018 uh which i think
suggested that uh the level of
brownfield land uh was about 40
with the with the new sites that were
added
when the airport was removed from the
local plan but i can
check that figure and come back to
you councillor ashby if that would help
but i think the figure we came to was
approximately forty percent
it's a slightly uh it is a rough figure
because we rely on
uh some windfall sites which generally
tend to be
brownfield sites but are not always so
i hope that helps thank you mr vell
so any members wish to speak on this
item
no okay so um unless i hear any
objection i'll take the recommendations
as approved
thank you um that concludes the business
for tonight's meeting
um i declare the meeting closed at um
i make it 17 59 thank everybody for
their time members and officers
um wish everybody a merry christmas if i
don't see you
in the next week and um thanks to
everyone who's participated the live
stream of this
meeting will now end